Speaker 1: We sort of haven't talked in a way
about the war on Christmas, which doesn't exist
for a while because there was a Republican in
office. So let me refresh your memory as to how
the war on Christmas works. It doesn't actually
exist, but now there is a Democrat in office.
So Fox News wants to fully resurrect the war
on Christmas when a Republican is in office as
president. The story is Democrats want to
wage the war on Christmas, but thankfully
we've got a Republican president, so they're
not going to succeed. That's the story. When a
Republican president is in office, when there's a
Democratic president in office, the story is the
full war on Christmas routine. The left wants to
cancel Christmas. They want it to be illegal to
say Christmas. They want it to be illegal to be
Christian. They don't want gifts. They don't want
anything, OK. This year, the war on Christmas
under a Democratic president is combining with
the possibility of supply chain issues, delaying
Christmas gifts. And so Dr. Fauci is being taken
out of context. When he was asked last week or the
week before about large Christmas gatherings. It's
all being ramped up and kind of rolled together
now. Here's a little compilation we will play.
This is from the recount. Very nicely done.
Speaker 3: The supply chain crunch that
threatens to spoil the holiday season. There
will be things that people can't get toys not
getting shipped. Toys like Tonka trucks, Tonka
trucks, Tonka Truck, yeah, my Little Pony caravan
Speaker 2: type of things that make or break a
Christmas and a lot of care bears, Tonka trucks,
My Little Pony. We've showed you the kind
of trek from the bear at a factory in China
to the store in Massachusetts. This is
the togetherness care bear and everybody
needs to be together and everybody
needs a hug. They're going to be
harder to find if people can't get
bacon and people can't get a Tonka toy
Speaker 1: should be Joe Biden. Yeah, that
would be. That would just be terrible for
Joe Biden. So then the House Republicans tweeted
a picture of Joe Biden with the caption quote,
This is the guys who is trying to steal Christmas.
Americans are not going to let that happen,
and I know it shouldn't be, but it's still
shocking to me that people continue to fall
for this stuff. A headline While Peter Doocy
was reporting from the White House, Red Toy
Association CEO says it may be too late to save
Christmas. Then at another moment when Peter Doocy
was reporting it said White House scrambles as
supply crisis threatens Christmas. Neil Cavuto had
an explosive story with an interview even called
Christmas tree sellers hit by supply chain delays.
And then on the opinion shows I know right on the
opinion shows. Laura Ingraham had a story called
The Biden Who Stole Christmas. Sean Hannity then
ran an almost identical story called The Grinch
Who Stole Christmas. But there's a picture of Joe
Biden in a green suit and tie. Yesterday morning,
there was a segment on Unfiltered with Dan Bongino
that might be a Fox News online show. Maybe it's
an actual TV show on the weekends. I don't
know. The segment was called how the Biden
administration is stealing at Christmas. Aaron
Rupa reported on Thursday last week that Fox
News mentioned Christmas at least 106 times in the
prior 24 hours. This is sort of like the epitome
of the cultural replacing, the substantive for the
American right wing. We've talked about it before
this particular story, the whole war on Christmas
thing goes back to Bill O'Reilly and some of those
types in the early 2000s, they started this in
the way that it exists now. They started it in
the early 2000s, saying Christmas is being banned,
saying Merry Christmas is being banned. It's an
attack on Christianity. They're trying to diminish
Christianity, et cetera. The the real genesis of
this story is that there were some companies that
decided to be marginally more inclusive by saying,
Hey, you know what? Let's say happy
holidays. That's basically the story,
and everybody was fine and life continued. And it
was no big deal, but that was what started what
is now known as the war on Christmas and now just
perfectly supply chain issues melding with it. Dr.
Fauci's comments about Christmas, which, by the
way, we'll follow up on on today's bonus show,
he's saying if you're vaccinated, it's probably
fine to gather. Actually, that blended into it.
And now Fox News is utterly determined to
resurrect this war on Christmas. Incredible.
But they're succeeding. This is the type of stuff
that does well. It gets ratings. It gets people
angry the same way. We've got to stop socialism.
Really? What is socialism? Oh, it's Biden. What?
Yeah, it works. It works. And they have no policy.
And that's why they're doing it. And you're
already seeing war on Christmas stuff show up.
It's it's it was early October when it started.
It's already there and now it's building
and all the usual online enclaves.